para el ángulo agudo y que es este que
tenemos aquí abajo el seno de va a ser
igual a 5 entre raíz cuadrada de 41 y la
cota en gente de hacer igual a 8 decimos
encuentre los valores de las otras
razones trigonométricas para resolver
esto quiero usar zocato a nuestro no
mónico para recordar las definiciones de
nuestras razones trigonométricas vamos a
escribir lo son
y todas
y nos dice que el seno del ángulo que
nos interesa que es el va a ser igual al
cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa si
vemos este ángulo en el cateto opuesto a
este ángulo
es este que vale 5 entre la hipotenusa
que es el lado opuesto a este ángulo
recto
y vemos que es raíz de 41 así que aquí
tenemos información redundante ya que no
están dando también en el problema aquí
vamos a escribirlo de todas maneras esto
es igual a 5
entre la hipotenusa que es raíz de 41
ahora pensemos en el recíproco del seno
que es la co secante de ccoo secante
como es el recíproco vamos a invertir
estos elementos de manera que nos queda
que es la hipotenusa entre el cateto
opuesto y como tenemos estos valores
simplemente los ponemos aquí va a ser la
cosa cante de igual a raíz de 41 el
valor de la hipotenusa entre el valor
del cateto opuesto que es 5 ahora nos
toca revisar el coseno de aquí el mónico
nos dice que el coseno de e en este caso
vamos a escribirlo por acá coseno de e
es igual al cateto adyacente a entre la
hipotenusa vemos el cateto adyacente de
a es ésta esta línea que va de el ángulo
e al ángulo f y está marcada por esta
etiqueta que dice a así que aquí no
conocemos el valor todavía más adelante
lo resolveremos vamos a dejar está aquí
ya que todavía no conocemos cuáles son
el valor que tiene
pero la hipotenusa si sabemos que es la
hipotenusa es raíz de 41 así que aquí lo
sustituimos como raíz de 41
aprovechamos que tenemos ya el coseno
para encontrar su recíproco que es la
secante lo escribimos
secante de e el recíproco vamos a
invertir los valores va a ser la
hipotenusa entre el cateto adyacente
conocemos el valor de la hipotenusa que
es raíz de 41 y aún desconocemos cuál es
el valor del adyacente o de este lado
que también coincide que tiene la letra
minúscula así que va a ser esto la
hipotenusa entre a para que quede más
claro aquí voy a señalar con respecto al
ángulo e cuál es el cateto opuesto en
este caso este lado es el opuesto
o puesto
este que lado que está opuesto al ángulo
recto es la hipotenusa y este no cambia
siempre va a ser este la hipotenusa
hipotenusa
y este lado que es etiquetado como a es
el lado adyacente al ángulo
adyacente
entonces quedamos que nos falta nuestra
última razón o nuestro último par de
razones que es con respecto a la
tangente nuestro armónico nos dice todas
está en gente de
tangente de igual al cateto opuesto
entre el cateto adyacente
/ a
sabemos el cateto opuesto conocemos el
lado es este vale 5
aquí sustituimos entre a que es el
adyacente y aquí me falta poner una
adyacente y no sabemos todavía cuánto
vale este lado así que le dejamos la a
aprovechando que ya tenemos la tangente
vamos a encontrar su recíproco que es la
cota ingente la escribimos la cota en
gente del ángulo e es el recíproco de la
tangente por lo tanto va a ser a entre o
adyacente / opuesto que es igual a la
literal a del lado adyacente entre 5
ahora necesitamos encontrar cuál es el
valor de a para poder terminar de
encontrar bien estos valores en nosotros
el problema nos dice que la cota en
gente de
vale 8 decimos y aquí acabamos de
calcular que la contingente de es igual
al adyacente entre 5 por lo que vamos a
poner que esto es igual al dato que nos
están dando en el problema que esto es
igual a 8
decimos cómo podemos resolver esto bueno
tenemos por este lado entre 5 es igual a
decimos podemos ver que este se puede
reducir ya que tiene un factor en común
tanto en el numerador como en el
denominador pero también lo que puede
hacer es despejar a como lo despejó
bueno voy a multiplicar 5 en ambos lados
de la ecuación me va a quedar que esto
se cancela 8 por 540 decimos es igual a
40 decimos
cuando intento 10 va a ser igual a 4 a
es igual a 4 y ya que tenemos el valor
de a pues lo que resta es sustituir esto
en las razones trigonométricas que
acabamos de encontrar lo que la tangente
de va a ser igual a
entre 4 la cota en gente de ella
habíamos visto que era 8 décimos pero
aquí sustituimos y nos queda que es
cuatro quintos si multiplicamos el
numerador y el denominador por 2 nos va
a quedar que esto es igual a 8 decimos
por lo que estas dos son equivalentes
también vamos a sustituir está en el
coseno de de manera que el coste no deba
ser igual a 4 entre raíz de 41 y
finalmente la secante de va a ser igual
a raíz de 41
entre 4 y con esto tenemos resueltas las
razones trigonométricas que nos piden
ahora podemos verificar que
efectivamente este valor de 4 es
correcto si usamos el teorema de
pitágoras que nos dice que la suma de
los cuadrados de los catetos va a ser
igual al cuadrado de la hipotenusa tengo
el cuadrado del cateto opuesto es 5 al
cuadrado más el cuadrado del cateto a ya
siente 4 al cuadrado esto debe ser igual
al cuadrado de la hipotenusa que es raíz
de 41 al cuadrado
nos da 5 x 5 es 25 + 4 x 4 16 esto debe
ser igual a 41 y efectivamente 25 16 es
igual a 41 por lo que esto verifica que
nuestro resultado de a es correcto